oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
raconte moi quand tu étais un peu de
gêne à dire on fait drame à dire on
n'est jamais malades alors n'y a pas
d'eau médecin mais un goût comme silence
dans ce palais je n'ai pas entendu crier
le grand yaka de la journée on ne veut
personne tout évident de silencieux les
schémas tâche est dure chara m'ont pas
vraiment aux femmes
l'urgence nous voyons les schémas péché
cherchant qu'à et 8 mois restant sur un
bon je vais me renseigner pour faire du
bien malade
voilà voilà voilà grand yaka buvait judo
à acheter non je n'aime pas une petite
bière
je veux de la tisza les demies cool là
oui oui y'a qu'à une tisane de miku cool
je reviens grand yaka que je suis
content a pas sur ma vision que je joue
à être malade et muscat mouskouri sites
et musées comme qu'on me dira ce grand
gars il fait le malade pour se faire
dorloter et là on va voir a toujours lié
chez boîte à chier urgent est mon cas
c'est tout le grand gars cas n'est pas
malade il s'amuse à ton père fou rire
avec ton plateau à la main qui tu es
fier de ce que tu dis et je croyais
arrêt tu peux me croire aux l'air tendu
comme je te vois
ce grand yaka mériterez dans nos bons
dans l'enfant lé dakor marque est
toujours une petite leçon titus mon dieu
le cosim alors mosca mathiesen de miku
cool et grand cas j'ai trouvé mieux
qu'une tisane je vous avais d'un médecin
l'illustrent titus kahn qui est évident
c'est énorme et je ne veux pas de
millionnaire
alors allons grand orient ne vous vengez
tepa voyons cette maladie je sens dans
la fièvre là dedans et de jean pelletier
par votre chef avec cet appareil domont
un moment donné on aura nos gros fuck
garoua aucunement dur globaux ne voit là
une fièvre sérieux qu'il faut soigner
énervé comme envie d'écouter monsieur
lemay de chez vous vous trompez pas je
n'ai pas lâché prise
elle prendrait que l'illustrent petit
comme s'ils ne se trompe jamais nous
avez la pierre de chaillot présent le
système nerveux le dudit site et nord
pas de calais comme ça me ferait bien
mal en point
voilà si tu aimes bien 9h30 sur 2006 je
vous assure voyons le poumon à présent
non respiratoires
prospero et louis nord frappant de
transpirer pour vous
et les dauphins communs je le trouve et
vous même dans tout mon travail et non
au tram ou c'est grave pour moment
extrêmement gras est ce que je suis mais
leur ds3 mono mal à vous guérir et c'est
vous suivez mes d'instruction il n'y a
qu'un gros maire
ed dans ma vie je n'ai pas sommeil et
dramé ben lobb
bon alors je te c'est tout c'est surtout
le sommeil et la fente et voilà mon
temps au titre quel petit é ça va faire
trois jours deux vaincus moi je vais
danser avec des émissions qu'on le grand
yalgado les pourris dans ça et après en
fait c'est une autre histoire
[Applaudissements]